If you just read the Quran, it is halal,
it would just it would be halal to have
sexual intercourse with a 5-year-old.
Chapter 65, verse 4.
>> Imagine being a Muslim, a young Muslim,
you're like, "Man, I I I feel like he
crushed David Wood. Man, he's killing it
at at Speakers' Corner. Man, Muhammad
Hijab is he's doing it." And you open
this clip. What do you think that does?
>> [music]
>> So, one of the funniest blunders that we
that comes to mind, man, is when he was
debating David Wood. There now there's a
quite a few in here, but he made an
astounding admission, and he didn't even
realize it when he did it. Look at this.
And he's here saying that he prays to
the prophet. There's a difference
between
lahu and you salli ala in the Arabic
language. I knew this was going to
happen.
I knew this was going to happen.
I just want to join in on this. I think
it's
>> [laughter]
>> worth a lot of here. We knew it was
going to happen, Muhammad Hijab. Go
ahead go ahead and explain what what
what what's the difference here. Go
ahead and tell us.
I knew I was going to have to give you a
free Arabic lesson here today. Masha
Allah.
And that's why the translators put for,
not to the prophet.
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, no.
>> he just say? Did he just say that?
He just said, guys, that Allah prays for
the prophet, not
>> makes it all right.
>> Now
>> [laughter]
>> Oh, man. That fixes it.
I Either way you go, he's praying, man.
That's the point, man. Like, so he's
affirming David's point, and this is
when Muhammad Hijab was just starting.
The blunders began with him, and they're
going to end with him.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah. But, you know what's funny? Why
are the Muslims clapping?
Why are they clapping?
Allah prays, guys. Yeah.
>> He prays for. Okay. Straight zombies.
Now, now, what do you guys think is
something like this does? You know, you
have somebody, you know, in the Muslim
community, pretty pretty huge, who's
acknowledging that Allah prays, but then
the Muslims are clapping. Like, yeah.
Yeah, you did it. You sure did show him
when he repeated word for word what
David said, that Allah prays for
Muhammad. What What is this What is this
How does this reflect on the Muslim
people when they're clapping for this
stuff, man? It just shows the herd
mentality, you know, mob mentality, that
like, "Yo, this is our guy. We have to
back him. We have to support him no
matter what. Even if he says something
that we don't even agree with, we have
to support him." So, it shows you that
even in their own religion, they'll say
things that they don't think are true,
just so they can support the guy that is
behind the microphone. Yeah. And so
>> Blind loyalty. Which reminds me of
another another blunder that he that he
made here. I think it'd be fun for us to
look at here. In the same same debate,
same day. Same day, ladies and
gentlemen. Look at this. That
that Jesus This is called the etymology
fallacy. That's, you know, he's been
referred to as Immanuel, etc. God is
with us. Elijah is also
The word Elijah in the in the Hebrew
language means God is with us. Oh, no.
So, if if that makes Jesus God, then
Elijah is also a god.
Oh, no.
>> [laughter]
>> If Jesus is God because he's identified
as Immanuel, God with us, then Elijah is
also God because Elijah, guys, also
means God with us. Did you guys know
that that Elijah means God with us in
Hebrew?
I don't think anyone in the world knew
that before Mimi just told us. So,
Muhammad Hijab, hopefully you've learned
by now Elijah, Eliyahu, means my God is
Yahweh. It doesn't mean God is with us?
Doesn't mean God is with us. It doesn't
actually. You know what? I I I
I looked it up. I did just a quick
little search in our time here, and uh
what pops up is this, exactly what Jai
said. Uh
Eliyahu means my God is Yahweh. That's
what it means here. Not God is with us
or God with us. What in the world is he
talking about, habibi? Come on.
>> And this is their this is their guy.
Yeah. This is their clapping for him,
and they're cheering for him, and he's
saying false information time and time
again. Now, here's the thing, cuz, you
know,
there's such thing as making mistakes.
You can retract like we all do we we
make mistakes, we misspeak, but you got
to be honest and humble enough to be
like, "Okay, yeah, I misspoke or I made
a mistake there." And and and go with
the correction. He never does. He
doubles down or tries to lie about what
he said, right? As if we wasn't it's not
recorded, and we didn't just watch you
and hear what you said, man. So, that's
what makes this worse is that he lies
and tries to cover up his mistakes
instead of admitting them. But, this
goes to seep into it seeps into the dawa
community, especially with the with the
young ones who's watching this. They
adopt this type of mentality when they
see him do this type of stuff. Uh there
is actually a clip of Muhammad Hijab
doing that very thing at Speakers'
Corner, where he actually says, "Oh, you
thought I was saying praise? I was
saying praise, like p r a i s e,
praise."
But, we all know what he was saying.
But, you you can't praise for. Right.
>> [laughter]
>> If you want to praise, there's no two or
four. Now, this this this leads us to
another blunder here, man. Let's just
We're just going to pile it on here and
see
see what we got. This is a beautiful at
Speakers' Corner. Look at
admitting here. You look just at the
Quran, Mhm. you will get the indication
that you can have sexual intercourse
with a 5-year-old.
Oh. Halal to have sexual intercourse
with a 5-year-old is not found in the
Quran at all. If you just read the
Quran, it is halal, it would just it
would be halal to have sexual
intercourse with a 5-year-old. Chapter
65, verse 4. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us who you can divorce and who you
cannot divorce. And then he says, "Wa la
ilam yahidna, wa la i lam yahidna." And
the ones who have never been pubescent
before. And by the way, this is very
important, yeah? I want all Muslims to
be aware of this. The reason why we
don't have sexual intercourse with
5-year-olds and 6-year-olds and
7-year-olds or whatever is not because
of puberty.
Whoa. Wait, what did you say? It's not
because of puberty, because that verse
He he he even said, "Yo, whoa, what did
you just say?" He
>> [laughter]
>> You know, he's he know he understands
how that how that hits the ear. Yes.
>> [laughter]
>> He's like, "Whoa, what did you say?"
He's
like, "I'll I'll I said what I said."
And look at the faces of those Muslim
women. Look at those faces. Yeah. What
y'all going to say? Let's Let's see
Let's see him do this again.
With 5-year-olds and 6-year-olds and
7-year-olds or whatever is not because
of puberty. Wait a minute, what did you
say? It's not [laughter] because of
puberty, because that verse in the Quran
actually says lam yahidna. They never
had puberty before. You can't go around
that. The Quran doesn't say doesn't say
anywhere in the Quran that the woman has
to be pubescent. I dare you to find one
verse in the Quran where it says you're
not allowed to marry someone based on
harm, or you're not allowed to have
sexual intercourse based on harm, or
you're not allowed to marry someone
based on puberty. Get me one verse in
the Quran which says the woman has to be
pubescent. Y'all hear that, Muslims?
This is your challenge. Bring one
unequivocal verse, one unambiguous
statement, where Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala himself says that you're not
allowed to marry someone based on
pubescents, based on harm, based on
maturity. Give me one verse. This is
what he challenges you to do. Wow. Wow.
Yeah, the clear Quran is very clear on
that point. Oh, yeah. Very detailed and
explained. Fully detailed and explained
here. Mhm. Now, he thinks he he thinks
he's making a case. He thinks he's doing
a favor because he's arguing against the
Quran-only Muslim here in the context,
and he thinks he's doing like he's
making a, you know, like he's really
showing it, you know. He's about to
damage this Quran-only position, which
it does. It does. But, bro, you are a
Muslim. This is your book. And you are
acknowledging that based on your book
alone, it is very clear and explicit
that child marriage is okay. That
there's no age. 5-year-olds are up for
the taken, according to the Quran.
Something that we've been telling you
guys from day one. But, we get called
Islamophobes. It's cool when he do it.
It's a problem when we do it, man. Now,
let's let's finish it out, cuz we only
got about 30 seconds more of this clip.
I want to see what else he says here.
Give me one verse in the Quran which
says the woman has to be pubescent. No.
You know, in the Quran it says
you're not allowed to marry It says
you're not allowed to marry your mom. It
says you're not allowed to marry your
sister, your auntie. Where does it say
you're not allowed to marry a
prepubescent? I'm looking for one verse
that you you can say you pinpoint it and
say this is where it says prepubescent
marriage or whatever is not allowed. SO,
IF YOUR QURAN ALONE, you're still
towards pedophilia, and [laughter] a
severe type of pedophilia, wife abuse, a
severe type of wife abuse. Whoa. Wow.
Did you hear what he just admitted to?
Yes. Wow. Yes. It's better than
apologizing to us. That is crazy. Yes.
Yes.
>> That is your book, dude. You're talking
about your book. Mhm. Man, talk about
throwing under the bus.
>> Abuse and pedophilia, he said. Yeah.
Wow. So, what you you can't you can't
argue against it if you are a Muslim and
you follow the Quran, you cannot say
that the Quran does not teach this. In
fact, it's so clear, he broke it down.
He said the Quran goes so far as to give
you examples of what type of relations
are forbidden. You're not allowed to be
with your mom. You're not allowed to be
with your sister. You're not allowed to
be with this and that. It lists uh
different relationships that you're not
allowed to have, and not once does it
say that you're not allowed to be with a
child. That's what he said. That's his
argument. Yep. So, if you are if you
believe in the Quran and you're
following the Quran, this is what you
have to deal with. Pedophilia and and
woman and and uh wife abuse. That's what
he says. Imagine being a Muslim, a young
Muslim. You're like, "Man, I I I feel
like he crushed David Wood. Man, he's
killing it at at Speakers' Corner. Man,
Muhammad Hijab is he's doing it. You
know, he just destroyed
uh William Lane Craig. And you you you
open this clip." What do you think that
does? Man, that's their guy. That's
their guy. And he is correct. That
verse, Surah 4:23, lists all the women
that you can't, you know, do it marry do
it with. And there's a long list.
Mothers, sisters, aunts, paternal and
maternal, etc. etc. etc. Not one in that
of that list is p- p- p- pissing you
off. Yeah.
>> Wow. Let's see. There's So, there's
another clip that we want to see. I
think it's probably the biggest the
biggest most destructive blunder that
Muhammad Hijab has done of all time. You
guys have an idea what I'm talking
about? I think it has something to do
with holes. I think it has something to
do with holes, man. I think it has
something to do with holes. Let's check
this out. Look at this lady.
Who remembers this faithful day?
>> [laughter]
>> One question. To try and make this as
specific as possible, I think.
If I were to give you a blank mushaf,
yeah?
And
and tell you to write what is munazzal
verbatim from Allah
into that mushaf with no human
interference, would you write something
which corresponds
>> It's not an easy answer. It's not an
easy yes or no. It is enough for the
Muslim to believe that the Quran is
preserved.
>> or no? I I have to Okay. Very very well.
So, ya Muhammad, after we get off this
phone, call me and you, let's have a
number of discussions. No problem. I'm
very open with advanced students. But
these issues should not Look, it is
kalam Allah what is going to be written.
It is kalam Allah. It is the What would
you What would you write? Uh that's not
Let's You're pushing me. And I'm saying
it's not hikmah to Listen, I have a
condition. Like I said, everything I say
is going to be factual. If I wanted to
do taqiyya and whatnot, I would do it
right now in front of you. There is no
need for taqiyya. The Quran is the
uncreated speech of Allah. The Quran is
preserved. The Quran is known. The Quran
is mutawatir. And alhamdulillah, all of
the qira'at are the Quran. All of the
qira'at are authentic. Alhamdulillah.
Leave it at that, ya akhi. Beyond this,
honestly, I have no problem. We'll have
a discussion or take my class. But
beyond this requires background
information. It is enough for the Muslim
to know that the Quran is the speech of
Allah that has been protected. And what
we recite is the kalam of Allah. That is
enough for the Muslims. I I appreciate
you saying saying one thing.
There you I appreciate you saying that,
but but
>> [laughter]
>> But I need you to tell me if you can do
this verbatim. Can you take a blank book
and
and and and put down the words of Allah
in the Quran exactly the same? Now, J
and Y please, you know, there are some
Arabic words being used there. And what
were they referring to, man? Because
a blank mushaf, you know, and and why
was Yassir Qadhi so tentative and and
hesitant to go into, you know,
Hijab's, you know, game there? Okay, so
the answer to your last question, why
was he tentative, is because he knows
it's a lie that they've been telling
Muslims. The mus- the mushaf, which is
the Quran, is the same from the mouth of
Muhammad till now. And there is no doubt
what it is, and it's all the same
everywhere. Because if that's the case,
he could have written it down. Yeah. The
Arabic words he said blank mushaf A
mushaf is a copy of the Quran like that
it's a physical copy. So, he said,
"Would you write something without any
inte- interference from humans as we
know that Allah said?" Would you write
something that corresponds to what we
have? And he said, "It's not an easy yes
or no."
>> It's not an easy yes or no. Wow. Yeah,
so you could use that if you want to any
Muslim who says we have one Quran. Or
you could use some of our other material
about what the differences are between
the different ones to show why Yassir
Qadhi would have said that. And the
Arabic word that he used, he said, "I
could use taqiyya right now, but I'm
going to be straight with you." So,
taqiyya is
a form of Islamic lying Wow.
>> use where you use double meanings or
what is called double entendre. Mhm. A
double meaning or a being ambiguous on
purpose to give a different impression
than what than what the truth is. Wow.
>> Imagine if you had a New Testament
scholar on the channel, and you were
asking about the text of the New
Testament. And imagine if he said to
you, this is a scholar, and he said to
you, "Well, you know, I could lie to you
about this." Mhm. What would you I mean,
this is
This is their scholar. He's saying he
can lie to him. And it just just
mind-blowing. So, after this interview,
you have they both upload on their
channel. Soon after, comments are
disabled.
>> Mhm. Soon after, that part is edited
out. Soon after, they're completely
deleted off their channels entirely, and
they're copyright striking anybody who's
clipping them or playing them on their
channels. Yeah. That's what happened
after that. Hundreds and hundreds of
hundreds, and I've heard thousands have
left Islam because of that very topic.
Thank
Muhammad Hijab. Thanks, Yassir Qadhi.
And that's their scholar.
Thank you, guys. Appreciate it.
Appreciate it. Now, it's it's now it's
something like this, as heavy as this
is, because it's dealing with the Quran.
And this like people convert to Is- to
Islam because they're told that the
Quran is the only book in history that
has been divinely preserved, right? They
try to compare it to the Bible. The
Bible has textual variants, so you
can't, you know, can't trust that. Oh,
none of these books have been perfectly
preserved right down to the letter. But
the Quran, that's the only one who that
has unique this unique type of
preservation. And so, when this hit the
airwaves, it blew the Muslims' minds.
Like they could not believe it that this
was really said. And it's being, you
know, it's an interview being had by one
of their heroes, Muhammad Hijab, right?
And Muhammad Hijab, right there in the
vi- He can't He's not correct. He's not
correcting the guy. And he doesn't have
the ability to correct it. He's not the
scholar that Dr. uh Yassir Qadhi is. He
can't contend against what he's saying.
So, there he's the one who's the student
listening and asking the question,
hoping that he's going to confirm the
bias of all the Muslims. And he got his
bubble busted.
Logic.
>> [music]
[music]